Welcome back to the ledger. To master insurance operations, you have to speak the exact language of underwriters.
Let's start by permanently clearing up the single biggest point of confusion in the entire industry: risk versus peril.
Risk is defined strictly as the fundamental uncertainty concerning a loss. It represents the actual subject matter of an insurance policy.
Underwriters split risk into two categories.
Speculative risk can result in either a gain or a loss, like buying stocks or betting on a game, making it entirely uninsurable.
Insurance deals exclusively with pure risk, which can only produce a loss with absolutely zero chance of financial gain. We manage risk through four distinct methods: risk avoidance, loss prevention and reduction, risk retention, or risk transfer via an insurance policy. Now look at peril.
Peril is not the uncertainty itself. It is the actual immediate cause of the loss. The unpredictable event insured against like a fire, an earthquake or a shipwreck.
If a peril is the cause of a loss, what makes that loss more likely to happen? That is a hazard. Hazards are factors that actively increase the chance of loss from a peril and underwriters classify them into three distinct buckets.
First, we have physical hazards. These are tangible, structural, or environmental dangers that you can physically see or touch, such as stockpiling highly combustible goods inside a building, leaving exposed electrical wiring uncovered, positioning properties in low-lying flood-prone areas, leaving an open manhole on a walkway, or driving a vehicle with defective signal tail lights.
Second are moral hazards. These are internal vulnerabilities directly related to the psychological character, integrity, or honesty of the insured individual. Examples include outright dishonesty, a poor credit standing, or an alarming history of numerous past losses.
Third are morale hazards. Notice the spelling difference here. Morale hazards are factors rooted entirely in a person's negative attitude, carelessness, or deep indifference to a loss simply because they know they are fully covered by an insurance policy. This looks like poor property housekeeping or a complete lack of basic loss prevention measures.
Let's talk money and calculations. When an insurance policy is written, the face amount listed on the document is called the total sum insured or TSI. This number represents the absolute maximum limit of the insurer's legal liability.
To activate this liability, the insured must pay a consideration value called the premium. The strict general rule of the industry dictates no premium equals no policy and no liability. The only legal exceptions are explicitly documented credit terms or an established structural grace period in life insurance contracts.
When an insurance company totals up its premium production over a specific period of time, that baseline sum is called the gross premiums written or GPW.
But taking on massive amounts of risk all alone can cause a company to go under. So insurers protect themselves using reinsurance. Reinsurance is literally defined as an insurance of an insurance. The primary insurer shares a portion of their total sum insured and premiums with another professional reinsurer.
When you take the gross premiums written and subtract that outsourced reinsurance data, you are left with the net premiums written or NPW.
So who calls the shots behind the scenes? The underwriter is the operational gatekeeper whose duty is to select, evaluate, accept risks, set terms, and determine the exact amount of liability the company will retain.
To operate, every underwriter must be fully licensed by the National Insurance Commission. When policies are sold, they use intermediaries. An agent explicitly represents the insurance company.
Non-life agents can represent up to seven companies, while life agents can represent only one. Conversely, an insurance broker represents the client.
Brokers must be fully incorporated, registered with the Securities and Exchange Commission, SEC, and require a certified soliciting official.
All of these gatekeepers use the law of large numbers to calculate precise loss probabilities. For a risk to even be considered insurable, it must meet five strict structural criteria:
A large number of homogeneous exposure units, minimal catastrophic or simultaneous loss probability, a highly definite and measurable event, an economically feasible cost, and a calculable chance of loss.
Next up in video three, we are taking this layout straight into the courtroom to look at insurance contracts.